nicht hinsehen davon ist so eine art
werden wir uns wahrscheinlich nur
irgendwas anderen gute nacht ja es ist
so eine art wär ich muss irgendwas
falsch machen ein sprechender bär aus
peru der sein zuhause verloren hat
bekannt aus den wunderbaren
kinderbüchern von michael bont das
sollte ich aber finde
doch er findet obhut bei einer leicht
angeknacksten familie
natürlich hat der film nur sehr wenig
mit den team kinderbüchern zu tun
kinderkino darf ja markt sein und
paddington wuchtet genügend grünen kreis
klopper durch die gegend hin und wieder
mit sehr derben humor
und natürlich ist der film voller moral
am ende sieht wirklich jeder ein dass
man mit tugend und weltoffenheit viel
weiter kommt dass sich die lehrsätze mit
dem klamauk ohne krampf verbinden liegt
einer schauspielerischen leistung des
ensemble sally hawkins ist als mutter
wunderbar verteilt news bonn will spielt
den familienvater mister brown
überzeugend spießt einnahmen haben wären
überhaupt mein name ist nicole kidman
liefert eine erste sahne schocken ab die
den kleinen kerl ausstopfen
doch die wichtigste nebenrolle hat eine
absolute ausnahme begabung bekommen der
sagenhaft unsympathische mister curry
wird vor dem charakterkopf peter kipp
aldi gespielt kann ich ihnen helfen
junger mann derzeit wohl einer der
besten britischen schauspieler überhaupt
langes telefonat oder sie legen hier
unten auf werbematerial aus
sie alle bringen pennington ein
hocheffektives hin und her zwischen
traurig und lustig in gang
ein erwachsenes squash spiel gegen
kindergerecht papier ohne trennwände
zwischen komödie und tragödie